are you most looking forward to playing
again everybody I'm ready to get in
there probably most looking forward to
playing against LeBron LeBron James now
we go back since AAU so I got to play
against LeBron I mean greatest player to
ever touch the basketballs we gotta play
against him KD I played on KDC so it'll
be really cool playing against him I
know Devin Booker for sure tomorrow
right now he's a champ I gotta see what
that Wildcat talking about against KD
for sure Russell Westbrook he's been my
favorite player growing up I continue to
watch him throughout his career so it's
gonna be cool to really you know share
the basketball court with him